every week dozens of new manga chapters
arrive to entertain
all of us consumers jiu jitsu kaisen
my hero one piece hajime no ipo i can go
on
and on about the manga that i fervently
wait for be it weekly or monthly but
something that often goes forgotten is
what goes on behind
that awaited weekly release the blood
sweat and tears that manga authors or
mangakas
put into creating a mere 20
but what is just 20 pages a couple
minutes out of
our day for us readers is a week of
non-stop
work little sleep malnutrition and
stress for the author
anime like pokemon have shed light on
the life of amangaka
in a very realistic way and the sad
truth is that being a manga writer is
essentially voluntary enslavement
meeting deadlines living up to fan
expectations
company expectations and their own
expectations as writers
thinking up a plot today i will go into
the sad and dark reality of being a
manga author and the extreme toll it's
taken on
countless authors to this day
after getting picked up by a big
publishing company like shonen jump
though you would expect it to get easier
from there this
is far from the truth for mangakas there
are no breaks
the weekly schedule for most mangakas
relies on less than
six hours of sleep every day a number
that reduces usually the bigger and more
popular the manga is
eichiro oda the author of one piece and
the biggest manga in the history of the
world
is reported to on average sleep only 3
hours from 2am to 5am
another source claims that these three
hours actually consist of only 30-minute
naps
every four hours so
why is time so limited
well you have to imagine creating a
short story from start to finish
all within one week and all of the
processes involved
after turning in the previous week's
chapter on sunday the cycle begins
anew immediately according to an
anonymous mangaka's schedule
from noon on sunday to 5am on tuesday
and consists almost entirely of
storyboarding
deciding on panels what characters
appear in each the story of the chapter
how it ends essentially planing out its
entire structure the only break in that
long period of time is two hours for
sleep
and one hour for breakfast that is as
long as you consider meetings with their
editors as
still work of course and you can tell
from the rest of the week
just how packed it is coloring the
panels shading
working on the final manuscript only
three hours of free time
exist in the entire week excluding
eating and sleeping which are
the bare necessities but again to return
to the idea of voluntary enslavement
that i mentioned
earlier because it does seem rather
harsh we have to remember that
it is voluntary mangakas despite the
terrible schedule
do this all for a reason yoshiro togashi
the author of hunter hunter which is
notorious for taking
long periods of hiatus stated that
it has come to the point where either
the story concludes first
or i die before that happens but i do
intend to finish it that end game looks
rather bleak considering hunter hunter's
current hiatus chart
lines with primarily breaks for the past
years
but we can never underestimate the
passion of a mangaka
likewise oda told his current editor
when he first joined to die
for one piece mangakas are extremely
dedicated to their craft
of course sleep deprivation isn't the
only cost of being a mangaka either
sitting in a chair for so long working
on manga
leads to numerous health hazards they
can develop diabetes despite
almost all mangakas being very skinny
and almost frail
tendinitis can develop in their hands
from drawing so long
something that is so common amongst
mangakas that it isn't even an
expectation that they'll get it
they just accept it as a way of life
one of the members of clamp a female
mangaka collective who
created card captor sakura among other
names
suffered from lumbar compression
fracture in 2011
because she spent too many hours hunched
over her chair and straining her back
drawing
tagashi the author of hunter hunter also
deals with aggravated back pain that
prevents him from consistently putting
out chapters
other series like vagabond and berserk
despite being some of the most highly
rated manga of all time
also suffered an early fate due to
health concerns of the authors
this culture of overworking yourself
isn't
exclusive to mangakas however as the
concept of
karoshi death by overwork
is very prevalent across all of japan
in 2016 it was estimated that one in
five workers were at risk of karoshi
this is so serious of an issue in the
country in fact
that the government passed a reform bill
in 2018 that
limited overtime and fined violators for
overworking
japan is a very collectivism-oriented
country
prioritizing their group's success over
individual
kona shiomachi made an illustration in
response to
the 2015 death of an employee due to
karoshi
the key line being if i move one step
further in front of the train
i wouldn't have to go to work tomorrow
the idea of karoshi is reflected in
people dedicating themselves to their
work
and employers to an extent that is often
not just
prioritizing group success over
individual
but it comes at the cost of individual
health as well
be it physical or just mental well-being
kishimoto masashi the creator of naruto
while the series was still being
serialized never had the time to take
his wife on a honeymoon
despite being married for 15 years
type kubo the author of bleach once
spoke in an
interview at san diego comic-con on how
his appearance at comic-con was far from
a vacation
as he had to draw any chapters he missed
before he went on the trip
which considering the anonymous typical
schedule for our mangaka that we looked
at earlier
i have no idea how he was able to fit it
all in
just another testament to a mangaka's
dedication
and of course these problems exist on
the condition that the mangaka
does make it their manga makes it into
shonen jump or another renowned
publisher and they get
popular because if they don't get
popular enough then they can't afford
assistance a valuable asset for any
manga writer and have to do
all of the work themselves filling in
lines
backgrounds shading all of it on their
own
the pay is also nearly criminal the
assistant to the writer of prince of
tennis gave the figure
at about one hundred dollars per page
and though that could mean about eight
thousand dollars per month for a weekly
author
producing 20 pages a week this is before
taxes and hiring assistants which will
of course detract heavily from it
though it isn't necessarily terrible
relative to the insane schedule they
have and overwork
it is certainly not comparatively enough
getting an anime adaptation can also
drastically improve the
exposure and popularity of the manga but
then
as we see with one piece for example it
is still far from
easy oda is one of the most hard-working
and overworked by extent mangakas out
there
no matter how big your manga is it is
always
rigorous and constant work
and this all continues until your series
finishes whether it is
of your own accord or not because it
isn't just as simple as writing a
chapter
of one big book but instead creating a
new story every week that has to attract
consistent attention
and remain exciting and interesting
otherwise if the fans don't like it the
company is quick to drop you
after all there's no shortage of new
manga coming out in japan
they can always get someone else on the
other hand
in anime like bakugan we saw how the
company pressured the mangaka to
continue the series
despite the author feeling like it
reached its natural end already
sometimes companies will do this because
the manga is so popular that they can't
afford to lose it
which means that sometimes even the
author of the series themselves
don't have full control over their own
story
however this isn't a super common
occurrence
we see authors like tite kubo who
decided himself
that he would draw bleach to the
conclusion he wanted despite health
concerns and critiques from the editors
which is again another reminder that
this enslavement
is still voluntary at the end of the day
when you look at everything put together
it's a rather
unavoidable problem be it due to
collectivist cultural standards
karoshi meeting deadlines or just the
mangaka's
own desire to finish what they started
the process of creating manga is
difficult to say the least we can only
hope as readers that the reward they get
from working
creating something that resonates with
us fans and succeeds
is enough for them manga is truly the
life work of
anyone creating it and so we do have to
be grateful for everything they've done
for
what do you guys think of all this leave
a comment down below
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses